well ladies and gentlemen Monday I'm
back from Vancouver want to thank the
Comedy Works five sold-out shows comedy
words mmm how many mix you guys see I'm
confusing because it's details monkey
Comedy Works is where I'm going to be
this weekend in Denver correct
and I meant become two completely
different it funded one videos in Denver
yeah
both great spots both great spot ones my
hometown now yeah one is I'm gonna ask
you yeah
did you ask permission good amount down
when you come my city yeah leave me yeah
I get the key
no I know you do no no I get the key
I don't you but I'm just saying that you
didn't I just need you to hear something
you don't tell me what the [ __ ] to do
hey hey no you go you give them you can
prance around a mint state you want I
anything like you'll intern answering
you know check in with the church at any
state yeah any state you're free now huh
timber is to people you are taking with
you ready for this yeah one you include
John Elway John I'll get you pay your
specs
all right now if they just big boys big
boy yeah yep you [ __ ] look at those
white Chiclets yep and you suck his dick
got it was great gum wall to gums that
big old smile yep young run here I'm out
that mouthing I have how the family of
four
yeah runs at City he's got a mouth that
can house a family of four keep going
and there's one other yep he's I'm not a
Roy brown and you bring them out if you
come to my town right you don't get
permission now let me let me say
something to you I appreciate what
you're saying Noli camera yeah also you
want things ooh hey is any better watch
your P's and Q's halide you I have
controlled my pocket until the mile high
to my high city
don't go that easy now listen all you
gotta say is Maha snake in the grass
okay I win just what that's the code
word snake in the grass
for just having empty seats let me
explain something to you and I
appreciate what you're saying I do but I
want to say the same thing I said the
will sasso is from Vancouver and I went
to this weekend now if we will give you
the same kids yeah no I said the well
I'm gonna say this to you now I know
these are your towns I know you've had
some girls in those towns back in the
day too
I know there's a territorial thing here
born and raised you found out new
married man married man but yeah
to understand something if I get the
devil in me and I and I grab hold of my
piece and he's all he's only has a full
all kinds of ten-hut he's all old and
angry all old and angry angry man next
door by if I just if I wanted now I
won't but if I want please understand
yeah I was younger any your ass in your
ex ass it's a success
yeah I'll round up your girls and all
such those girls and I'll put them in a
room and I and I you know I'll say pick
a spot in the world all girls and
they'll be have to do it and I'm loo
take 450 old piece my married piece I'm
be crying I'm gonna be saying my wife
I'm sorry honey but this is on principle
I'm not doing this for pleasure I'm
doing this to mark some territory you
understand mark some territory well you
guys get up again I'll take the flat
hand I'll take this hand right here and
I'll take the cross your face I'll slap
your face no slaps I chose face now
bloody you guys up I'll put you in a
room you guys can [ __ ] each other hey
you old [ __ ] listen I've got to listen
no we call you in Denver
what you know Charlie what you you are
you a mile-high Alley Cat
for 50 year olds particulars in Denver
yeah really good take care of themselves
yeah you know Ellicott that's true but
here's the thing I run out of breath
when I'm up there for Mom sure do I'm
like nothing to do I was doing an
ostrich I wasn't wild bit as an ostrich
and I was like other guys dick super
super they didn't actually said it's
very fence in yeah it's thin and by the
way I just want to say that that image
of me you know having girls around I saw
that in a porn once where they all are
counting they're in a circular room yeah
I seen they were all had a button ear
and ron jeremy was poking all of them on
the button well I have diving in their
in their magazines and I thought to
myself that is such a perverted strange
thing to do these girls are doing this
for a job they're all friends probably
they're all in slow-mo semi-circle and
the Hedgehog
with all that that hair on his back he
looked like the [ __ ] bear from the
revenant if the parrot got caught in a
fire heywhat and it's the big I got in
the fire Death Valley and I found a
bucket of chicken wings every day of his
life I got a belly in a long bag why the
[ __ ] do this is my flesh and run Jimmy
then we get off this but
I think the reason why he was so big is
because he looked like most creeps out
watching porno back then like if you had
a big dude with a cockatiel on him like
an iguana dick yeah I can't really
relate to that few can yet he looked
like your average creep in the basement
jacking off the well he had a dick on
him too but it was a big old Banting
once you bring him up for a second I
wanted to have you ever seen him chin
yeah I saw him person I saw at the
Comedy Store
oh yeah pretending I didn't know Lila's
yeah now he hangs there he's uh it says
hi hey you said sorry time all the time
it runs early come here no that's true
time doesn't do a lot of porn stars so
well you know name what it's done was
when he was younger
let me see a look at him with you from a
nice Jewish family with a brother right
there was that amulet that talisman
hanging from his chest I know it's a is
right here no young and that must I
found notice on you going down keep
going at all hey girls
ok go to the left come on oh yeah what
brother he's sure John give with a
speckling a hair and a piece on him all
right you know what back then he's
probably doing work yeah putting young
ron jeremy i want to take a look see the
young one look at him on a swing right
got that one now is well says that food
is more important to him apparently he's
got a lot of money does well will during
my own the work and bring him up there
we are
he's a good-looking dude back then it
looks like jay shell he does he's got a
body
masculine harriet ears [ __ ] hairy but
some girls like metal well you know
here's a bush in those porn yeah yeah
and there he is when he's real super
fake uh let me see this one chin yeah
let's bring that one up
thank you they're a proud he looks like
a [ __ ] he just looks terrible hey all
right not bad
you know I ya know when it gets hard its
I've seen his work a lot seen his work a
few always working with again well by
today's standards it's interesting cuz
guys today have you know there's some
guys out there although some portals you
see like yeah I like where there's you
want to quit I don't want to quit I mean
it looks like a god where'd you find
that - yeah and all those it can be
to generate on how graphics these days
during avatar I don't it's real you
think it is I know it is I've been on to
Daddy okay I said that I'd been that's
it I was on set once when markets the
black porn star was there and he came on
said hi and this girl named Nautica
Thorne was getting ready to a scene and
he goes he just saw her in Boots and he
goes she was posing and taking pictures
and he was gonna have to have sex with
her and he goes he's goes oh [ __ ] he
starts he starts brothers dead kinda
nudging got it no other way to mom's
nudging his dawn look in the old dawn
Darwin and his cargo shorts I was like
man I gotta get the [ __ ] on the office
under like hero buddy doing I'm right
here oh oh oh my did I think it was like
you yeah II get like heavy night you
wake somebody up a was up gonna hey come
on
yeah so brother pushing it up from the
[ __ ] up bro we just roll that off it did
so fatty it's like leaded he does well
it's a she a does [ __ ] yeah he does
what well can't their tail yeah I said
no reason and as big and so was was said
his the other his co-star I remember
this all coming back to his co-star
halldor's you got a [ __ ] this is this
was when this was right before I did the
Jessica Simpson pilot I was still doing
jujitsu that's how I knew the wild girl
yeah
and I thought to myself I'm bout to a
Disney ABC show and I'm on a porn set at
one point I was holding what we there
was holding a reflector I had never
ceased wanted the experience I wanted I
was like I'm on set and we were on we
were outside there was a tiny red couch
overlooking a cliff I'm not and so we
were chilling out to ingesting a man's
private property overlooking the valley
wealthiest yeah but it wasn't a house it
was his property and we went outside
somewhere it was unbelievable then the
guy came up on the house and kind of
nodded and smiled and kept driving and I
couldn't get out of there fast enough
after a while I was like alright I'm
watching these two guys plow and when
Mark is who doesn't love yeah when
Marcus actually gave me one of his
t-shirts he had t-shirts had also merged
the wrong he wasn't even telling me goes
here you go and he gave everybody a
t-shirt he's very sweet guy and I also
should say I think
I said something like Marcus I don't
know just Marcus could do but he when he
blew it was it was like the it was like
somebody released Niagara Falls and his
buddy
gizelle says how the [ __ ] did you when
was the last time he goes man recently I
don't know the [ __ ] just came out and I
was like well congratulations sir
Jack diesel and not good Lauren was it
was about what about us it was it weird
to see just two people or three people
just do you feel bad for the girl I mean
I if you really let me get into it when
facts what happened to Nautica was that
she she got a little tear and so then
they decided to do a little [ __ ] and
that was the way they're going to end it
so yeah so it was interesting is that
never know what's gonna happen on so
what what did that [ __ ]
yeah now that the guy who's holding the
boom and the guy that's holding the
reflector there all day all Act a lot of
times a lot of times they're also actors
so they were like an a newer and they're
like well I guess we're all Journal and
she was like I guy and I was like what
the [ __ ] is going on here the hair color
and he's like a baby bird she's like how
many random dudes busted I was a with
one two three four five ah I feel sick
yeah I I was and everything was cool
everybody was super nice they see each
other before they shoot and everybody
gives them each other their bill of
health and they look at it they read and
I was seeing if they'd read it right
they read it then they hug and and they
go yeah that's with now let's move on
from porn well when I met you today you
look like a beekeeper you hat on it's 90
degrees out you got a [ __ ] lavender
[ __ ] your mistake wearing a hat yeah and
and sunglasses you know you look like
you beekeeper well that's because um I
have skin cancer no you don't well
like Andy Kaufman you seen any comments
are when he ever he says he said he had
cancer the [ __ ] grounds so much no one
believed oh yeah well he died well I go
yeah exactly I go to the doctor said
that it's on my back little itch
we kind of just liked it always always
it yeah but I noticed that there was a
little like a little like a mole and my
my wife was like it's the same saying
it's the same and I already go on Ryan's
a hypochondriac
yeah you're always worried anything like
just 2/3 like I do not only to the fall
now having said that though I don't go
to the doctor ever
in the last month you've been goddamn
well you've been more you've been to the
doctors more liquor - well no I went
here when I got a coma because I had
quit 50 I'm just saying I hadn't had in
my first checkup in two years right so
actually pretty bad about then going
today well now I gotta go actually
because I go in last week that thing for
my thing that it was just a
dermatologist whose ancient and really
sweet guy goes well it looks completely
benign is just up it's just a mole I
think you've it's just flaking and I
think you've just irritated it I said
we'll take it off because it itches it
takes it off they put it in a jar I get
a call and the nurse goes well it looks
like you got yourself little I what's it
called squamous cell I go what's that
she was going to cancer um it's from too
much Sun and I go well is that like a
basal cells because now this sounds a
little bit more on the surface if you
got a really get because it can get in
your body I went well let's go ahead and
[ __ ] she goes we'll see in three
weeks I go oh or how about right now
about down there come on not being
casual about my back cancer hey you know
in the sun that much well you know what
though I grew up in very hot climates
and Saudi Arabia and Lebanon and Greece
and you're out laughing I was always out
with my shirt on
often back then what about race on
blinds it does it work like that like
back hell yeah doesn't work because now
you're not really in the Sun you why
this [ __ ] right but it doesn't matter
because it's a lifetime accumulation all
that's out now good news is is highly
curable and I got it early here's the
problem you know I gotta get my face
checked so you know if they if you got
on your old stacy Pacey they got they
got to start digging in and my buddy had
another Lucy on your face somebody had
on his nose and he had to get he goes aw
it's fun they stick a bunch of needles
in your nose dead not that feels really
good when you get needles in your nose
they got to cut into your nose do you
don't have anything to say so we'd see
spots or so now sometimes it can be very
know you've been weave it or not a
convenient with Brian texted me we used
in Vancouver
I was busy wouldn't talk that much
gesturing did you call me I think Joe's
got cancer and my Jeff was getting right
and I went are you seriously just
[ __ ] being weird there's no serious
and I calmly
yeah cancer well I got to be now going
to live like a vampire
do you know just out
one spot or they said did they say you
gotta say other son forever yeah oh yeah
oh oh yeah life type lifestyle change
I'm not the son that I had or yeah
because any kind of exposure the son can
create you know your dog man though yeah
shut the old school movie
I can't I'm shooting himself I can't be
getting you know you get a little
something on your face and I don't feel
like having them shave off layers
broseph that what they can do that would
make them yeah they can do it it's just
it's just they figure out when I there's
white people's way worshiping you of
course but I'd still annoys me that I'm
mister healthy and then that happens the
fact I can't stop it's not about diet or
anything little not only healthy people
who just [ __ ] catches up me if it's
something genetic or too much sauce like
Sally
and by the way wear sunblock because
it's it's kind of crazy
there's at more cases all the time
really yeah I'm in the I will on all day
yesterday my shirt off in Monday you got
some dog backing out good pool
I got pool in my undies you got a dark
skin you got dark skin but you shouldn't
you should put inside don't you have
good nah don't worry about that probably
about that at all paying ten years later
means I'm talking I have it on my face
yeah I told you a teacher canceled out
her nose same thing Sarah nose go on
summer break shows up listen we're sick
great we're pretty she had no no a
little bit no nose goddammit nose was
off covered up just like we're supposed
to be cool with it yes that's a
nightmare in nightmares I don't like no
nose she literally [ __ ] yeah Yorkers all
well no no he yeah it's probably unless
you're an avatar we can fix it i seconds
on nose back which you know i love that
[ __ ] you know what dude in like 30 40
years you be able to grow your nose back
up be dead ten years build go Dino's
back yeah well [ __ ] man I need it NAT
sound like it was a melanoma but I don't
know this but this lady I'm gonna call a
[ __ ] mrs. roach dead now passed away
mrs. roach had cancer
yeah start off on her nose look pretty
squishy pretty toxic yeah some break
comes back it'll get in here
I'm not talking straight up gone are
fine cloth just talking like you [ __ ]
everything's all getting everyone fixed
grades like hey how old was humans you
knows probably every bit of 70
yeah and then setting up you know I'm 34
send up the projector you're really a
threat not notes where that they do that
they put all the notes isn't clearly
rather notes if you'd have to ride it
all night kids will have to do it these
days but uh they put the cord like a
cross you didn't see it cuz missing the
nose you boo Falls I haven't laughed
that hard in my entire life
I'm sixth grade right now it's not by
the way the reason it's important to
know that Brennan is not who you go to
for sympathy as I'm out there with my
hat and my sunglasses he's going like a
BK a beekeeper I'm like dude you know a
little respect
I'm I'm so you're worried about you
let's take just such like being a little
bit of a dramatic yeah your kid I
guarantee you're telling your friends
and family I'm already it's all my
sister my mom because that's all I need
there's nobody all forget it the minute
I tell my sister and my mom they're
going to be like I'll be getting calls
every single day to go check this go
check that how do you have to do that
you know what if I if I ever had
something like you know that's right
that'd be the bad be the biggest pain in
the ass dealing with them and their
stuff I didn't see that movie 5050 they
do no reference laws so fifty-fifty with
Seth Rogen a brilliant actor first
Gordon Joseph gordon-levitt yeah yeah
he's great but um so he has cancer and
she was saying how annoying it is like
you know telling people and that oh my
God he's like Anna please stop crying
like yeah [ __ ] me I'm sick of dealing
with it every every day yeah
same thing why there's a hospital these
kids with cancer or they know that
horrible things going on with their
lives and I was with the shooting a TV
saying there we go
you can't feel sympathy or show that you
know that you're sad for these kids
that's all they get they need to get
away with you got it yeah they're dying
well I was one kid I would two kids I
can't take kids by like my little eyes
to walk out on world as far where that
guy started dancing started popping at
the guy at his buddy's funeral I think
that's appropriate
it was great then the other guys started
dancing and they were all cheering and
stuff because the guy they were
celebrating his life that's that's well
that's one school of thought that I
appreciate sometimes to have like a
celebration yeah
I said I want you to celebrate don't be
all sad of my funeral hold me I did a
whole dance I don't know depends on age
it does but he's 21 is like a whole lot
murder and you're like I thought up a
pop on I back up
jump family like what enough [ __ ] that's
like not he wanted [ __ ] hot pop it
popping my girls [ __ ] did I tell you
the my acting teacher would always tell
the story about his thing was cousin
died at 16 years old overdose on the
couch in the grand so you can imagine
right and the brother to brothers and
the sister and mother and father it's a
disaster and their one uncle then they'd
never see he's at the funeral and he
leans over and he's like you know he's
like a plumber he's like this guy who
owns he had a clip-on tie but eclectic I
tie came just up to his nipples it was
the shortest tie and he leans over and
he goes my Nepali my my apologies on my
condolences on a Canada brother my
condolences condolences my condolences
that I thanks Uncle Bob and then they
see his tire it's dankey it's just a
little clip on tie and [ __ ] there in
the front and everybody's there and and
the sister I mean this is their brother
that it's the worst thing you can
imagine is this is good
did you see it and they start to laugh
and the whole family starts lab you
think they're crying but they're their
ears right and they were like we can't
show them that we're laughing we
actually should be crying it's a little
I thought they were having a breakdown
just humor everyone of course there's
humor everywhere this [ __ ] humor ever
around hostage situations what was that
hostage situation they were talking
about how the people were telling jokes
they were [ __ ] challenges what else
you going to do that a buddy in high
school known forever you went to YCA
tony clark he was a problem child got
into drinking his buddies were out
partying like a Tuesday night the driver
was drunk he was in the back sleeping
they hit a telephone pole at Tiffany
Plaza movie theaters he went through the
windshield and hit the telephone pole
yeah I'm not laughing he went through
the difference you'd hit the telephone
pole headfirst
died by in fact her I got like you're
the funeral right now I'm bought like I
do not do well you're a mom you getting
wrong because I played lacrosse with him
I knew since he was young
we're friends he'd come over our house
so red this year I'm just balling my mom
and it's an open casket and he went head
first and sing and it's like god damn
man yeah and you know you go up to say
you respects him I don't know if they
just you didn't recognize him right I
recognize now it boast again it he was
like this and then it was like his neck
was like this and I went up this was
dying piece of framing I was trying to
bang for the longest wasn't from me oh
my god this is terrible timing committee
how horny we'll cut right through the
sad moment what I like Tony you'd want
this she wants me to [ __ ] this girl Anna
but um I get up there and I just go to
Rio look look at the bone in his neck
and it was like something out of the
movies on the kick and you all he could
do is very [ __ ] me like this my ha ha
man yeah like ah it was horrible man but
it's but there is humor everywhere you
know kind of worried terrible person
well I mean uh I think sometimes when
the only option is to laugh you know
that's kind of what you're looking to do
though that was terrible cuz his brother
at the time when always do not but was
in county jail or prison
he came in he you know he got the news
but I guess I don't know how it works
what they like I've done the funeral he
comes in with death scored with four
cops orange suit chains on his feet and
hands terrible and he's walking and you
know I didn't see his family anything
anything what's up what's up you know
young kid going what's up man seeing
friends like what's up and then you see
him just look and sees the casket was a
brother yeah dude it was one of the
worst sounds ever in my life
okay when you say your brother scarring
us of all time I know of all time if
cancer comes it's the can tear out that
says it's gone now that Weekly I do know
it's gone I gotta go get my whole body
looked at now I can't wait for that day
even check your genitals you won't check
that balls got to check your ball sack
each other took don't can't wait for
that how about dr. Aubrey Marcus this
morning I go do Bri doing is I don't
think the same thing is he's doing a
project he's I do going to Miami does
something you can do it shock therapy
they shock your genitals men and
women and it's let's give you a crazy
sex drive for like three months
I went wouldn't do that man he goes yeah
there's a shot you can do that goes
through your prostate
I guess just gives you crazy sex right
for women they give you a shot in the
clitoris I'm I'm done good man one thing
for I'd like to say is I don't believe
that maybe that's what they say and also
I don't need a shot to my my prostate to
get hornier ah
look dude look metal I need they go they
go through tape yeah no I'm not doing
that
nah nah go and skip on that I'm gonna go
ahead and skip on the the needle into my
taint to stimulate my prostate so I get
even hornier I'm going to skip on that
the amount of work out had gotten done
in my life if I wasn't such a [ __ ]
pervert when he told me now I'm like - I
would never do that is relevant no I
don't have low sex drive or I'd rather
get on TRT anything anything but get a
shot in the dick now get needles away
from everything in that area
no no needles I mean yeah if you bring
Oh needle around my [ __ ] balls or my
wife and me because I forgot to drain
that thing for whatever reason would be
painful but I guess I'd you know they
have to do that yeah now if you have an
erection like to say take those dick
pills there's guys who you know on the
commercial I could be on the rectum less
want me to 72 hours 72 hours [ __ ] after
3:00 I'm gonna be a long got to start
cutting it off it gets black they don't
cut it off they go ahead and put the old
drainage in there is that true yeah they
thought they gave it gave you shots of
other stuff can you bring up well do and
you have a hard-on for everything really
for a blood I guess yeah because it's
just pulsating ah but what the blood
should pump back in there you're
thinking they give you yeah and I think
because because what it is is that you
have cavernous bodies in your dong right
the walls yes until they deal with that
way they deal with water but then I
think the inflammation can actually
outlast it long lasting how to be funny
for chin knew exactly what the beers for
fun is old history
that's a put put a put oh
what do they do if you can't get rid of
a erection literally right that what if
anybody has any advice on
squee myself they've had it email me I'm
interested so I can know what to do ten
steps with pictures sure
hiding direction [ __ ]
uh yeah put your hands and I plugged
into my pocket remember that covering
all this is all they all time a deal you
want restraint I'll let the clock I
called each time with a grandfather
clock text technique that's what I do
creating huge acts college is [ __ ]
stupid it's not talking about in the
funny we're talking level five terrorist
threat just for this election won't go
to treatment erection there has to be
someone medical treatment from prolonged
erection yes many men get the condition
when taking erections can't happen
without proper blood phone uh-huh
express it yeah low flow or ischemic
prep ISM now I'm looking for that needle
[ __ ] I know there's some stuff you have
to say black little spider I know
there's some stuff you you know the I
know they put needles in there
really now you might be right I don't it
might be to breathing can she just maybe
take it in the leg not the dick autumn
and there are different ways to do it
right they put can you drain your dick
with a needle right needle could drain
damage yeah 17 hour erection three pints
of blood drained what yes
where was I wanna go ahead Jason Jason
Garnett that's crazy had 17 hour
erection come on three pints of blood
drained from his penis 24 injections I'm
telling her man Oh what did he take
oh look at that dude yeah man well I
wonder how his dong is doing now I bet
that thing is just [ __ ] caused by
blockage of blood vessels the empty that
empty the penis ah leave that Jason
Garnett 23 could only watch in horror as
a doctor stabbed a cannula into the side
of his penis yeah
he'll do whatever you got to do look at
that hello he said seeing them stab my
penis with a needle was horrible like
something of a horror film they were
rejecting all adrenaline
yep into the dick that's what they do
within our allergic reaction right so
when you have like um when your
esophagus closes up I guess they shoot
you with adrenaline they'll say yeah
yeah they said he didn't take viagra he
just had a raging boner for 24 hours 17
hours well I guess there was some
blockage mmm oh my god yeah well there
it is oh there it is right there where
the picture of what I've been dining the
blood from is on the right right there
well first of all that looks like a
penis doesn't matter tiny piece was
confused I see
got to drain it I'll sing like a big old
Citylink of blood or you could see the
shaft right there mmm the shaft the dog
yeah either way that'd be a bad issue to
have did you know when your Vancouver G
is a chance to see the fight that all
the men I saw that fight and I I didn't
get a chance to I was on stage but I saw
his age electrodes under while you were
mourning yes and I think that was a case
of Chavez being um and this is my take
on the whole thing because you know he's
clearly so much bigger and um he
weathered a lot of luck he was just
playing defense right he was just
shelling up then he throwing up or
cautery Throwbot and i felt like i don't
know what it was maybe he felt like I
think it was a head case I think it was
a situation where he just decided not to
throw his hands and decide if he wasn't
as good and decided that he just I mean
for me that felt like literally felt
like a guy who didn't believe he
deserved to beat to be you know a head
of canola for real I don't do you wanted
to do it that's what I sort of felt like
he wasn't answering back at all he just
kept closing coming I'm used to throwing
a shot I think that was what I think
Canelo landed really good shots outbox
him clearly with his jab jab him all
[ __ ] night yeah his left eye which
covered up by the
the 10th round and round but I think he
felt the power and speed of canola GI
what a wise [ __ ] and then he was scared
to go out on a shield he's scared to get
knocked out
so then Canelo was demon Batum if he
knows Canelo can went for and just
[ __ ] up all night but he let him do
work against the ropes he's trying to
get mopin up to knock them out I mean
hard to not gotta get it takes no
chances I don't get almost impossible
well what he would do is he it was
really weird he would I guess that's
part of his style the shabbos would get
his head almost like hell and apart
umbrellas go do not stay there and then
ya doing work but he did work because
he's worried he could open up is out a
while that's and Canelo is beating them
into his own come on come on shamans
being so much bigger and I guy I was
surprised that the strategy wasn't to
keep him at bay with his jab and he used
the size and bully him into the corners
but what he was gonna do that he can't
he can't can I was too close too fast
too good Wow and he was too scared and
then Chavez just too scared and then I
thought he lost so many fans to fighting
the way day at boot I don't see him
fight as my healthy so I don't think he
fights again I'll know where he goes
after this it all seized hearts not into
it that's the biggest age can that met
the Mexican stage like that was your
chance to I mean if even if you would
have put up a fight I thought he's gonna
lose but if he just puts up a fight
right you can win over the Mexican guys
when you don't fight at all I could
traditional Mexican you don't ground
your shield but but here's my thing so
when you see you sometimes you can see
that that a boxers clearly outclassed
right like you could see that with the
Cotto Manny Pacquiao fight by the third
round you can see many who had figured
his whole game out and there's nothing
coded it would throw these jabs and he
was just getting beat up he was older
they're a little differently sure but
with and then you see the same thing
like god it makes you realize how good
for Mayweather's because i rewatched
that the canal mayweather like what do
you want me father little better it's
just amazing about how his defense and
how he stays out of the way now you got
Cannella who's obviously you know the
highly skilled boxer but I didn't see
him doing I didn't see him doing um
anything flashy what I saw him doing was
basic he's very educated basil bono
yeah jab oh yes he's a lot of jazz
throws and stuff but I'm saying mostly a
lot of one twos not he was plotting for
it wasn't a lot of like footwork it was
like he was
thing really it was like Lamont Django
is so elusive and I that that's so for
me I was like I felt like it wasn't it
didn't look like Chavez had the biggest
puzzle to solve when you watch Lama
chenko fight he's blind he do jump and
tell you like what would you know it
doesn't matter church fathers didn't
want to fight you don't want to fight
your fight did not doubt that he was
allowed to get fitted so he was being
super conservative keeping his hands up
on nothing bigger God defense fall
defense so strange man it was a tear in
what this is my promise
box right now I can't really last time
was this good Mike one of the best times
a damn box we're in the golden eight
this so many good [ __ ] fights right
now Spencer it verse Brooks is coming up
I think next week there's a heavy weight
division is great Romanenko you got
andre ward Kovalev you got all these
fights coming up but we have a
pay-per-view of this magnitude and
people are finally maybe boxing is back
and then they tune into it and you get
that boring ass fight I just party at my
house for 30 people
everyone was so bored man yeah I was
like oh my god yeah [ __ ] man
but you were able might be everyone go
all this is why I don't watch boxing
like a foreign of course yes but it's
different than your see because you're
seeking I have a horrible fight night
and then they stack those paper views
and there's five fights the main event
might be a stinker you put the co-main
event or there might be someone else you
know on the you know on that main card
that puts up a knockout whatnot you
typically not all we beat sleepers right
when boxing you live and die up that
main event like the Lemieux fight before
that I know main event
amazing how one fight from the museum
monster yeah
so that's a fun fight but doesn't matter
boxing lives and dies off the main event
so most people it [ __ ] the sport of
boxing clear that's problem boxing and
then they do that weird kind of
WrestleMania triple G inch
entrance which makes you make you go oh
well they had Triple D that all this
setup so they all see everyone assume
Chavez is going to lose maybe Chavez but
you know all it was kind of a plan this
makes you feel kind of shitty about it
oh you mean it was kind of setup fight
it was literally just like hey check out
Canelo vs. a bigger guy yeah and so I
was like yeah I'll be that guy
right I'm around I'm like gonna get
knocked down I think I think
one thing for sure is that triple G
ain't Travis that's going to be triple T
that's what I'm really looking forward
to because triple solace it triple G
does nothing but keep moving forward and
stalks you and hit you with those bombs
so into the bigger man taller man
exactly and Cannell does the same and if
Canelo tries to match triple G and his
power because he doesn't have the size
it's going to be that that's why I
definitely have my money on triple G
because if Cannell was gonna fight with
that style it feels like he's matching
the females all right but that's that's
a big liability against the guy who hits
as hard and is bigger and stronger and
is just skilled is triple G it's gonna
be tough it's gonna be a tough one for
him he started off as a I think fight
with the opening odds for triple G
Canelo stuff at five to one and I didn't
see it in time so I put money on Canelo
and it's already at two to one now most
of money is moving towards Canelo really
I think Canela beats Olivia really why I
think triple G's 35 I think against tell
Brooke that showed them that the way you
beat triple G is on the inside and speed
a progression well just on the inside so
whatever you want to put in the inside
so I think Canelo's better boxer and
Kell Brooks hits more you know he's more
powerful he's just a bet he's more vodka
Brooks yeah yeah really
Tamela yeah oh my cow Brooks is you know
tonight close far as really they thought
competition was huh I'm close calpico
Brooks's I guess I get a lot of times
I've seen a fight he looks so good and
I'm so broke yeah and I'm really looking
what do you think well he's a little
special right look who look who Canelo
has fought it till he fought every yes
he's the biggest drawn box for a reason
but um so I just I see I think Cannell
is only getting better and I think
triple G you know his last two fights
some people thought he lost his Jacobs
last fight you know like that last fight
was tough for him so I you know now's
the best time because I think if you
wait another two years
tribbles you'd be out of this primaries
35 with over 400 fight I had a lot of
fights like now's the time he's the big
six I think as me how old is he triple G
no yeah 35 35 yeah I told you ting Earl
Spence makes quick work of Kell Brook
now first no that's a great flood he's
phenomenal yeah 35 yeah Wow
um so now's the time for the fight are
they going to fight what weight are they
going to fight at I don't know but this
is what's weird because Cannell is the a
side what does that mean means he's the
draw he calls the shot oh it's a golden
boy promotion okay Canelo's the a side
canal always makes people come to his
way I can't wait maybe always catch wait
Canelo Canelo hasn't made a strict
weight and I fought by his last ten
fights I came in last fight he's made
the astral weight limits always catch
weight what was this weight that he
fought at 52 164 164 um more six four
and a half but um he's the a side so
it's give me somewhere in the middle but
it's gonna benefit Canelo and then the
other thing is is you know when when
Canelo it's interesting I heard I heard
him talking about his Mayweather fight
he's young 21 to 22 when he fought for
Mayweather he was undefeated and he goes
[ __ ] man like when we took that for him
a weather fight when it was gonna be a
tough fight we knew we didn't match up
very well then
we had to meet his criteria he goes hey
I never had to cut that much weight
before was a nightmare just to make that
way and then B we didn't realize how
fast it was he's like it's just a
perfect combination so we had to meet
all his demands cuz I was the B side he
was but that fight helped me because it
put him on that huge platform he's a big
strong boxer now a 12 round loss to
Mayweather is really not that big of a
deal now if you will got knocked out
been a serious issue but 12-round
decision made whether then he just goes
on and I was the biggest also make sense
for a young for you know like a young
guy that let me ask you this question
but back there points o Canelo you know
when you fought Floyd he was the B side
he had to make that crazy weight hit to
do everything that Floyd demand just to
try any type a day
well now Cannell has been they fight for
how many fights now he's forcing guys to
meet his requirements and it's a [ __ ]
yeah this exponential stops down a
Shamas right out there guys yeah if you
don't fight the pretty time before you
think that was part of it do you think
Chavez was trained no I mean I mean I'm
sure I'm sure is one of the fab yes but
really mentally just cuz your drain does
mean you don't come to fight right he's
made that way mentally mentally some
people
our content did you know coming in
second place I got [ __ ] for but I said
you know Shabbos tonight looks like a
rich kid taking a fight he he's 50 and
to his surgeon Martinez fight was very
soon with that and then he ended up
knocking Sergio down in the 12th round
yeah let's ask would but least he took
chances and then of all the fights the
one night you decide to fight like a
rich Mexican kid of the greatest Mexican
boxer of all time was this stage you
waited for this [ __ ] crazy man yeah
let me ask you this do you think because
like so there is a size difference
between you know Canelo and criminality
but do you think that the side that size
makes as much a difference in boxing as
it does in MMA um no Justin no depends
on the style and the matchup and the
skill set in MMA when there's a size
difference if I take you down right it
means it makes the world of difference
it tires right I might not even be as
good as a grappler but if I'm 240 pounds
and you're 200 pounds and he's gonna
it's gonna wear your hat off you guys
you tried to hold down 240-pound man
when you're 20 pounds or yeah 200 even
20 pounds of one's gonna be a bigger
another kinds a different striking
enough so you've not got power to me on
the guys side seems heavier right right
inside that but in boxing I do it all
the time all the time right all the time
well I mean Roy Jones jr. did you know
he basically fought hoodie fighting fun
he went hangin heavyweight yeah everyone
does I mean it's in Boston so they did
because but the weight difference is as
big of a jump as say from 70 to 85 in
MMA it's a huge that's a huge where does
80 fibers are cutting up from 220 yeah
and there's a light heavyweight to heavy
weight your time on a world different I
think your I grade the boxing never been
more exciting it's so [ __ ] good right
now
it just sucked man I catered [ __ ]
Chipotle
I don't know spread well I was in my kit
all of Joe's family if they're from from
Guadalajara to Nellis hometown it went
shirts on in shit's cool though I mean
why not and then literally just rant
rant laugh and then you know this shows
you how triple G's
be side when he came to ring Ellen oh
[ __ ] I got so excited with what's going
on well that this is like the matchup of
my lifetime triple G Busch canals the
fight everyone's looking for you never
heard of them is any good on that so I
spent the last 30 minutes didn't hear
any of them you had to watch on replay
telling people who triple G is really
[ __ ] on I know but think about the
think about the Anthony Joshua fight
with this every title oh yeah we got
another one coming up that they in their
contract they have to fight again right
ah no he can fight someone else okay but
if for that oh [ __ ] del that's a lot of
you have to okay it's an OPS yeah
alright but get that whole heavyweight
division looks good yeah Co blabbers
Andre Ward comin up I can't wait for
that that about Andre Ward missing uh he
missed the standard you and you have to
it's in your contract they do the
faceoff with Max Kellerman it's one of
my favorite shows it builds the height
for the fight Andre Ward missed it why I
used to do it I don't know that to me
I'm actually looking forward to that
second fight more than I'm looking
forward to Canadian canal I'll get the
[ __ ] out here Gennady can Canelo's
literally the best boxing match and say
I don't I I think that if you're a
boxing connoisseur if your boss it cuz
you think we've seen Andre Ward
Kovalev right Gennady verse Canelo is
insane insane why I don't I can't
believe it's even happened I still until
they actually touch gloves see but I
think this is been going on for so long
the skill level with Andre Ward in Cove
lives like answer words it's a higher
skill level than it is I think and then
Gennady in that why would you say that
well because Gennady to power began I
he's very skilled but he's a power
puncher looking just like just like
Kovalev okay yeah but a guy who owns but
I don't Maddie Olympic medalist and I
understand that Andre were called gold
medalist and also technically a better
boxer than Canelo
I mean why would you say that least
because he is but why Zion because I've
heard many people who know why Bobby Cox
he was the best guy Awards beaten
Kovalev his last fight but hopefully I
mean after getting knocked down look
over that and I saw Wayne
knock on doors he doesn't fight a lot
it's true but if you but he hasn't lost
since he was 13 years old now you know
you can say what you will that has
triple G but but you know people who
talk about him from Andre Berto to
Freddie Roach whoever it is they all
Virgil Hill Virgil hunter for that
matter but that everybody talks about
about how Andre Ward is the best boxer
period in the world
try Lotito is the best box well no you
know what Andre words usually not be
slushy now and max words list she's not
in the top four so we go lomachenko I
without those feet though Canelo is
usually up there do you think and then
triple G and then Andre what with triple
G and Andre award but both fell out top
five after last fight you think that
triple G and Andre Ward they've been
boxing a lot longer than Canelo even
know Kozma box which is 15 I feel like
they have more professional experience
as adults and I think that you can make
the argument to Rami triple G doesn't
have as much professional experience he
started well he's a amateur either way I
know the Russians have fought you know
they their amateur ranks are a long time
so that's true but at the same time for
all intents and purposes it seems that
triple G's been boxing longer than
Canelo right maybe didn't know so the 10
years Sol so already this is a bad
argument all of them have been boxing
forever so it's a bad argument and
Cannell has been in way bigger profile
fights his biggest draw in boxing and he
fought way higher level competition he's
been more active he's made certain
weights you know so it's so to say well
he has more they've all they all have a
shitload right at the top right it's a
shitty argument well what about what so
you think but don't you think is an
Andre Ward considered a more skilled no
a technical boxer than Canelo then is
even triple G and all those guys
no hmm he can remember he's heavier
right the heavier the just think of USC
so would you say Cain Velasquez's killed
as a fighter as Conor McGregor uh you
know why I would say that because his
wrestling is better and because his I
know you're getting at I know you're
getting at I know you're getting at I
mean I that's what the lower weight
class is the way yeah they're more scale
they also kayla has way more competition
so who's
who's Andre who's Andre Ward fight after
Kovalev name another flames light have
met nobody in that name another famous
guy he swapped the others only one
there's only one killer in that division
he's a defensive fighter yeah
Canelo's 49 in one pressure fighter
what's the bet fans fought the best of
the best who is gonna have fought in the
past two years
Lara [ __ ] Cotto Mayweather I mean
everybody got made with everyone it goes
I mean the winger he's fought the who's
who man I thought he checking Lee lost
that Laura fight but I mean let's go
through it Amir Khan killer knocked him
out well they're all killers Shane
Mosley Amir Khan [ __ ] Lara's and
absolute nightmare so it was a split
decision actually loss Ellen James
Kirkland who's a knockout RC knocked him
out in three rounds Miguel Cotto Amir
Khan knockout Liam Smith world champion
TKO body shots who their size junior
bigger guy Wow
Austin trout is in murder too it takes
all comers this is definitely his
biggest test triple G right yeah man
yeah yeah I don't let me no doubt I got
triple G just on on the fact that
they're both they have both similar
styles but triples he's a bigger
stronger man and if you try to say
walking out with triple G's oh they're
gonna slug it out yeah and I think that
he's a favorite if if he's ever gonna
get knocked out in his career that this
is when he's gonna get done oh [ __ ] yeah
I mean I know [ __ ] this is dangerous for
both of them
yeah cuz cuz uh Gennady golovkin showed
showed holes in his game when Brooke
Brooke got inside when broke down inside
he had some shots you eat some of those
shots from Canelo you're going down to
be fair apparently with Lemieux off so
the funkier who get you end up class but
to be fair um from what I heard Gennady
golovkin had the flu in that Kel Brooks
fight I already was sick some who'd you
heard of that was what they talked about
on
TV really yeah I was watching it so I
don't know that doesn't matter I mean
watches will have to do with technique
and fighting like there's a been a ton
of Jordan I had the flu and put up 70
points like the being sick really that
doesn't have anything to with your game
plan you really you know I mean you know
I don't know what like Alistair Overeem
was sick it he also ever had food
poisoning ended up flatlining mark on
yeah so it doesn't mean you know that's
a bad you never know I mean I don't know
what to what extent maybe his reaction
time maybe he was just depleted not as
strong or let's talk about because I
hate when people do that or Lestat get
to this kill Brooks is world-class come
looks looks great and that's like kid no
you know he made him of it not sick no
Brooks who extreme right it's lighter
[ __ ] yeah we can't say yeah Kanellis
that's why I'm really looking forward
will do fake something who knows
well does Kell Brook has no that's why
I'm looking forward to the Kell Brook
Oh Spence fight that's a great play Ross
mentioned a [ __ ] killer and again
that the same knock on girlfriend's like
well who's he fought you know you
getting there yeah all those guys who
get yeah it was very exciting man
biggest UFC of this year's this this
weekend this weekend you just realized
that this weekend and I'm your Enver
yeah you'd be on stage buddy oh of
course I will be who who is a big car
who are the big names here can we bring
that up for a sec JD yes JD yo Santos
yeah be pay yeah you wanna I got just
ban that hold on I'm just right sorry
Jesus crazy sorry steep a jjx you wanna
Jim Jay checked Frankie Edgar guy year
yeah Demian Maia Maas with all so who
Harold Pettis acronym
Eddie Alvarez Dustin Poirier is a
[ __ ] banger Jesus yeah but that's by
far best card of the year um yeah I mean
and and you know don't Frank grill on
the top left of it oh [ __ ] they
cancelled a kingdom oh did they yeah
it's no longer which is so that's
interesting will mate will the did they
just finish the season I guess they are
finishing the season off or something
like that or maybe they've got public
knowledge
yeah
what we get friend to boot yeah I think
it is public knowledge that's okay yeah
this is public knowledge I notice um so
you want to go through over sex just
make some predictions sure buddy Eddie
Alvarez Dustin Poirier go ahead well I
got I because I spoke to Dustin Poirier
on the phone this is the kind of fan I
am I was doing he made me laugh a little
bit I'm gonna go with us Cory and could
he does he look like a completely
different person with the big brown hair
cut III oh yeah you said with shaved
head yeah it looks great um I like any
others in that fight you do yeah that's
Emporia I think he's more skilled he's a
more skilled fighter in Eddie Alvarez I
think Eddie Alvarez is embarrassed with
his last fight with Conor McGregor it's
also kind of McGregor I think that any
hours so I mean you're talking he's a
Hall of Famer man Bellator champ mercy
champ right for his doctor a novella
torria Bellator champ UFC champ
stylistically it's gonna be tougher for
you unless he knocks him out early I
think Eddie Alvarez
where's is that sound also Poirier and
your boys going to hate this foot
Poirier whenever he fight if you go to
his record whenever he fights the top
echelon guys he loses hmm
he beat everyone not in the top five
typically now this could be the one that
gets him over the hill and you see this
a lot of times with a lot of guys but
look at his Lobby a huge michael johnson
maryland michael johnson fight they're
talking all that [ __ ]
johnson's ranked high at the time I
think top eight yeah it's Mert
let me get Jim Miller next you know Jim
Miller's done you know good night it's
over well it's also he's yeah last night
and then so let's look at top echelon
guys Mike Johnson ranked in the top ten
I thought Bobby greenery losses right
Bobby regard any fights Conor McGregor
loses fights Cub Swanson
upper echelon guy loses fights uh Korean
Zombie losses you know so that really
his losses are only the very very top
echelon guys now he did beat max
Holloway but this is super old-school
max Holloway right and it wasn't the
upper echelon max Holloway Xamax all we
had a shitload to learn
so but you know you beat some good guys
and he's [ __ ] amazing mates
definitely top ten guy but I just get
worried when he fights those upper upper
echelon guys and Eddie Eddie Alvarez top
three in the world no doubt so yeah I
got Eddie Alvarez via TKO or I'll say
decision let's go let's go in main card
so who'd overs Pettis um
Pettis look really good in this past
five I don't know never ceases our guys
that gold medal um is a great wrestler
and usually what if he gets a hold him
and get him on the grounds could be
trouble for real we're Sergio Pettis out
so I'm gonna go so we go see who though
hmm
what are you thinking so who's lost his
last two correct he lost a Benavidez any
last year I might have Mighty Mouse yeah
can't confirm that I think he lost just
gonna beat us because there's a coach
I'm Ultimate Fighter yeah he got stabbed
bad that I get stopped I feel I could
didn't Joey yep yeah I wasn't a split
decision here mmm to fight losing streak
to uh DJ just mert them um God that is a
tough fight for little pedestal little
pedestal thing with him is he's kind of
burst on the scene again so you got
Dustin boy who's a vet but still he
needs that breakout win got a little
pedasi needs that breakout win jacked up
the club taking hubs the bet against the
hooter though he's only you know Joey
Benavidez is by far the best flyweight
in the world not named Mighty Mouse
Johnson and if they're gonna fight for
what is it third time before time is he
by far you you put him in at a high
second who jory Benavidez yeah I mean
you grid you beat Sahu though by a split
to Siena
that's a tough one to pick the safe
route if you're betting Road be Sahu
though yeah I'll take pedestal I'll go
against the grain Pigpen go maybe so
break out fight for Pratt
I want to bet on that if you listen now
this I am excited about and aya
Rodriguez Frankie Edgar Frankie Edgar
man just amazing but um the yeah I'm
Mike my guess is Frank Yeager is going
to do everything he can to close that
distance and grab them around the legs
and get him to the ground and punch him
in the face and your your Rodriguez got
those crazy kicks that crazy Taekwondo
and that crazy in and out style and you
know he's younger
Frankie is holds Frankie now those
[ __ ] wars yeah you know everybody Bob
sighs how old 35 it's you know with a
lot of mileage and he's greatness but
it's a tough it's a tall order to deal
with a guy who moves that fast with all
those angles is kicking you from such a
long distance and I'm doing damage it's
the only thing he's doing damage against
who though name is the best opponent
he's beat you say BJ Penn I will take
out my dick and piss on everyone in the
air that was not a good situation
yeah I mean this is a test we'll see mr.
huge - yeah and guess what little little
fact for you yeah you're asked for this
fight really wants to do this when you
tell us that Nick's I don't know a lot
of us guys who fought so I mean Bruce
Leroy split decision then beaten I mean
BJ Penn you know legend hated paid to
see him in that fight get you fighting
again soon - yeah hated to see them that
fight yeah but there is there is the
idea I'm gonna go with your Rodriguez
because I'm gonna buy into the hype and
I feel like you're yeah you're right you
know what are you let's just go over
this let's go over this trawls Rosa
decision split Dan hooker decision on
jay Feely flying headkick ko that was
sick Bruce Lee Roy decision split a
sixty-year-old BJ Penn who didn't know
where he was that TKO here's what I
don't get what hype here's what I think
I think Gary Rodriguez is the new blood
he fights in a very unorthodox way
whereas Frankie Edgar fights in a very
Orthodox way traditional boxing great
wrestling I see
that that's easier to plan for even
though Frank Jaeger the best at it in
some ways and it's very difficult to
plan for how to fight a guy at that
distance with all those kicks and he's
got good - Jitsu he's got good
everything he doesn't know it's gonna be
tough he doesn't have good everything
not wrestling no wrestling ok but he's
busy I believe he's a black belt in
jujitsu right not a black belt
what is he think he's a purple all right
Frank Jagger's a black belt
grappling Frankie eats his ass up like
kobayashi yeah there's not a lot of
wrestling Mexico name the best Mexican
wrestler say who though he is American
he's American you gonna give me one
really good Mexican wrestler Wow
I got Cain Velasquez he do Mac American
Arizona State University track so you
know it's just not like wrestling in
Mexico is it you know something like
flow cranking the black gente black belt
here right high level wrestling college
so you know I just I'm not listen I just
with the black beast and I did this with
Robert Whittaker and I'm I'm both
they're nuts but was Yaya Rodriguez he's
gonna be that I think he eventually will
be the champ and he's fun to watch but
this test I just I just for three rounds
Frank Jaeger in there I'm a good luck
man unless you knocked him out with one
of those crazy flying knees Frankie's
bed just better at everything everything
and also name the biggest fight yeah
there's been time only or the main of
them on fight night against an old mummy
BJ Penn I think yeah here is difficult
to deal with I think he might be the new
blood Bruce Leroy takes a different
split decision
when was that I mean less than a year
ago like this is I'm not buying the hype
yet so August I'm gonna have to buy the
hype I'm going here here and I know baby
I just don't buy the high pop-up
decision unanimous decision split
decision unanimous KO decision split to
Bruce Leroy who is a very very middle of
the tear guy mm-hmm and then you fight
an old BJ Penn you guys do you got there
yeah Frank Eggers
legendary he's as good as any of any
awkward as an operator right now feels
disrespected and he just could see how
called out you mean well he thought the
UFC set him up he said you'll see wants
me out of the trying to build yeah yeah
yeah well yeah hold on my friend I asked
for this fight drama he wants to fight
the legends he wanted a title shot wants
always Galia well it's going to be a
thing that's going to be a very good an
exciting fight are we gonna see Jesse
Aldo Holloway the topic on this low B I
know but I just saw his name and I was
like Joe's a Hall Ian Holloway fightin
bazzill um let's go move on the next one
junior wait oh boy oh boy
tops wanna pick gave me a male model
well um I mean I'm tell you this right
now
if Demian Maia gives a milligram if
Damien my tries to bang with Jorge Mazda
and Damien - boxing has improved
dramatically damn em I was gonna get the
[ __ ] beat out of him all due respect to
the great Demian Maia but go ahead Alex
his [ __ ] hands Jesus I go baby before
right he's amazing my life breakdown
I picked someone I feel like I'm doing
the other way no well I mean Demian Maia
yeah it's it's like with the exception
Whitaker is like when when Jacare or
Damien might get to the ground we'll see
you later
that's the end of that but you're gonna
get him to the ground and or have
mustard I'll stand right back up I don't
know I got Matsu tall you think he takes
him down and Jorge just gets back up I
don't think he just gets back up I'm
sure I'm sure that he's going to do
everything can to stand right up and say
keep this on the ground
that's easier standing up might be
easier than try to I mean you know
anything else on the ground with Damien
the only thing you can do is stand up
I feel back and forth man and the reason
why I'm swaying now towards Demian Maia
no we bet chin on the live show but
remember Damien is a way bigger man damn
I used to fight night enclosed in my
used to fight at 85 Demian Maia beat to
show that Chael Sonnen to jail down with
an underhook
inverted triangle I'm from Mount
people forget name Maya was got a title
shot at 85 days I mean David Maya was
top five at 185 pounds he's a big dude
got he's got he doesn't have the reach
and he's no Damon Maya does have the
reach
now it's raise rates to 72 inches myself
74 oh really
though he's got longer legs 42 inches
verse 39 since we're interesting
apply the same height would you say no -
should be taller just a bigger person
and that's six foot bigger dude I've
never seen that mine or either one of
those guys in person I'm sure you have
my is just a bigger guy and you know
he's used to the bigger bodies it's just
it yeah you know I don't know why I took
this fight and I'm with Wiggly like you
it was stupid for him to take this fight
and I want Damon my to be the champ I
think it'd be great for it but why the
[ __ ] would you take this dangerous fight
man good why not wait and I will II
don't have opponent it's a challenge
Damian my a challenge no that is a
business number three in the world he's
been dying for a title shot yeah he
didn't know what to do that i from this
he's like [ __ ] it you said they you just
waited min you have a title shot in July
but now you're fighting this guy oh yeah
I got a win streak and he's a monster
and his confidence challenged is he I go
back and forth this one is the toughest
one on the card to pick back and forth
yesterday tomorrow we'll see that's what
I'm big brown breakdown we'll see I've
to decide by so so what so what's what
if you're coaching Demian Maia what's
your what's the game plan what do you
tell him get him against the cage you
get up Ray Charles in hearing like just
get him down the middle I mean that's
well yeah but you tell well I would say
you've got it well Danny Maya has a lot
of confidence in his boxing I'll tell
what he doesn't know he's gotten way
better he trains a lot of Commons with
he's not stupid he's not stupid he's not
gonna try to he's taking everyone down
but how are you gonna deal with that I
mean go to David Meyers red statistical
bread no but his boxing looks good he
sees his hands are free you know well as
conduct submission yeah girls Donna is
pretty good striking when she say
got three submissions and three
decisions that brown but more decisions
that he has submissions my friend by far
in this career by far which has always
been surprising to me it's like healing
doesn't submit as many people lately the
Rocket Man so maybe Carlos Condit
submitted Matt Brown talking to sure Oh
upper echelon right lead guys and then
Gunnar Nelson world-class grappler yeah
beat the [ __ ] out of this yeah
judiciary clinic and then Neil Magny
Stella Neil Magny
jujitsu clinic submitted him so out of
out of his last four fights he sent
three submissions against upper echelon
guys yeah but before that he had one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve decisions so he has a lot
of decisions as well in his record so
well yeah but if you if you this is
silly but if you go back to my little
skit or go to mods of all using like oh
well no he lost here he last here
Moslems lost 420 so here here's a better
question why lots of time a split
decision yeah here's a better question
if your Mazda obviously say hey do not
let them get you against a cage and do
not let them take you guys I mean
suspicious yeah this is Ameen Elementary
yeah that's it yeah this one my mom
could tell you both game plans and if he
takes you down what do you do get back
on the other yeah even plays get backed
up cage walked Caesar said and done
though yeah I go back to enforcement I
don't know yeah Mazel all I have Mazda
dog just because what like I feel like
he's just his mindset and he's just a
hurricane right now I mean I I was just
so impressed with him against Donald and
there's only one guys it's more of a
hurricane gave me money
yeah give me he's one in a row listen
you know I'd be very very I'll be a
quite happy for my legs but I'm gonna go
with Maz at all
no I didn't see you Billy he's just he's
a hurricane man he's just hard to deal
with it's like if Damien Davis gotta
have to stand there with him initially
anyway to get close enough and he's
gonna get punched in the face he did it
with 12 Honda who I would say is a more
dynamic striker than I would agree with
you or but would you also say that
Carlos Condit was at that point already
because you even said it almost felt
like he was kind of
one foot in one foot out which is a lot
so imagine I was not that though miles I
think this yeah so I'm just gonna have
to go with Mazda Dollface and Jem that's
fair man as I'm your back forth let's
move on to you wanna change a check just
go under aaj I go with a champion again
yeah this one's easy
this easy just quick Tomica really yeah
because you think Gianna has will figure
her out way better technique bond Raj is
just you know she's a power puncher um
that's where techniques not great I
think you'll wanna puts a clinic on it I
expired another decision but it's a
beatdown
it's a [ __ ] bully beatdown you want
to so [ __ ] good what's crazy is you
look at all these [ __ ] superstars on
the card and you on is the best striker
how funny that's crazy
that's crazy best credentials to Suarez
striking I made us move on main event
what do you got B I got everything jr. I
got to be back I thought speed baby him
the first time
yeah I really do I said Steve baby them
the first time I think dos an and you
know so I just to say it those we don't
know where he's at really like dota is a
record chin because he beat Rothwell who
you know he's a great matchup from he
sticks and move so we really didn't see
Joe Santos get tested and then you know
he got knocked out by over it yeah and
then he says he beats T pay which I
thought he lost that fight then he lost
a cane which took years off of his life
you know those those cane fights really
felt they did a man man but you know and
there's over him but really I mean if
you if you looked at it you know Kane's
got his number so if you take Kane out
of the picture why did Kane as number
though I think part of it was just
because Kane puts his head in his chest
and bangs away
what standing and yeah and and Kane of
course is such a good wrestler Steve
AIDS of college wrestler as well not as
good at came but Emma made you know
there's there's argument there but with
steeper he's a guy who he's basically
the white version
why Croatian Cleveland version of Kahn
black cave Alaska that's the big bigger
four-star fight in heavyweight yeah no
you not bigger West hauler he's a little
taller but they're very similar those
guys are a match made in heaven for ya
it's a very similar body came by has
bigger legs very similar styles and they
both can they both grind if the page
both box wrestle yes hard to submit and
my feeling though is that you'll see I
mean I'm also mad he just seemed steep a
scenes I have a great boxing he seems to
have something going on he has better
busts in G well that's what I'm saying
Jr Santos is is he would you say jr.
tends to the best boxer and well Cain
Velasquez a better boxer probably no
okay no no I think juniors are the best
like my hot doctor boxes and yeah not
killers
I'm still going to go steeper yeah I get
Steve and I love see play 1 the first
one all I want to see happen is that
[ __ ] Steve favors Cain fight that's
all I care about you want to see that
fight I want to see that fight nicely I
think the Steep a since Cain or since
steepening JDS fought in 2014 steep is
only gotten better and has more
confidence in JDS he's been gone for a
while he changed camps you know and so I
mean you looked at what [ __ ]
sea-based done take take out that Junior
dos Santos split decision loss actually
unanimous decision loss which I thought
he won that's yeah I thought he actually
won that fight just literally beat let's
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
really and I thought those when 8 wins
and wrought heavyweight and you're
fighting Junior dos Santos Gabriel
Gonzaga
Mark Hunt Andrei Arlovski for Doom and
over him you're also fighting on Mark
Hunt
Orlovsky and ver doom off [ __ ] crazy
streaks you're fighting these monsters
yeah his record is nuts man
it's not scary yeah yet steep a 2 it
doesn't go a decision I think there's I
think Steve a finishes them and the
second or third round TKO best card in a
long
[ __ ] time I'm excited me too man I'll
get pissed so hard I got it - I'm not
just getting needles and Drano dicks
like they go ahead and do that right in
our tanks be any painting we'd like to
do some current events now everybody
about the world we're going to talk
about things that don't matter
we didn't start the fire and I know
burning since the world's been turning
we didn't start the fire
you know is howling you know howling at
our Reebok oops I pulled all the [ __ ] my
wife my wife is like literally you guys
are the biggest idiots on the planet
better cracking up I'm guy Kim eyelashes
like you as you do it you need you
should ask and I'm like that's a yeah I
look do it fart jokes let's hear what
free barbecue whoops whoo there's
something about value hos Oh huh how
ridiculous is it
sometimes you gotta just fart in puppet
for no reason watts and Tim sorry the
worst thing when someone does on an
elevator and then they get off you know
you obviously you shouldn't like shut
out on a plane really get off and then
they come on on a plane come with a
schedule a near come on are you kidding
me yeah I'm talking me it's not good
yes I'm good I'm not loving you when you
turn over at me go remember we loved it
on air biscuit in superuser Nutkin drop
bring a cow to its knees bring a cow in
a power at the end of manure lady tells
us not a feedlot with manure everywhere
that cat would still go loser and fall
to a tree
okay and I go bro and you go I go
everybody can smell it you're just
sitting there going tonight I'm care and
I was like you have to start it remember
that well I well I would not do I mean
you know my favor hearing my back hammer
you probably from the smartness okay I'm
ready eating that cheese plate and
homeless and fard into it bro it wasn't
me and I went I feel sick Brian you know
I get sick on planes why would you do it
was it me and I was laying it on me was
and I didn't do it you did I guarantee
your old Aaron something video for that
that far though that onslaught of farts
in that air gave me accelerated my
[ __ ] backhand skin cancer your your
recycled ear it's not good in breeze
gardening I'm going to play
in Austria I think it's seven the other
flight that's going to be a lot of fun
now by the time you get there you're
older by the time you get there you'll
be 42 through muster with a heart
condition
all right on Australians you got to do
it for the Aussies we need to take the
fight on kin there I need to stand up
there I just it's a long daunting flight
for me but it's only actually how long
is it 14 those 1415 hours yeah but it's
just a long I'm scared it's so long I'm
scared a straight up scared yeah you'll
watch all the movies and you'll read a
book you'll sleep and then you're still
having a get a read on your stuff I'm
eight hours ago I'm gonna take you
sleeping pill there's a red-eye make
sense buck yeah because the time change
over there guys are so crazed you have
to caretta oh you do yeah that way you
give me the dad yeah yeah oh boy Aussie
Aussie Aussie what do you got - yeah
figured out look like [ __ ] out this will
brace yourself did you guys watch the
MTV Movie Awards [ __ ] bin decade had my
kid all day he dug it - so I was able to
watch it well together they give our new
award the gender-neutral award and Emma
Watson won it from behind so you know
all the like Best Male and a lead best
female lead now they just go straight up
best whatever man woman there's no
categories it's interesting it's so
politically correct and progressive of
them he was so happy about it so you're
it's a gender neutral so so in other
words it's what does that mean so there
is no more female male there's only one
it's all just it just who's the best
yeah there's not male female based off
of no categories biological sex likes
Jeff I don't I don't actually mind that
as much I'll tell you woloson are
tonight like I watched Emma Watson
yesterday in la-la-land
and I mean I'm a stone and I've been
acting a long time and I'll tell you
something that girl is it's good
together she's as good to get on him as
good she is
Titanic and I you know I watched her and
I watched like she's just a such a
natural movie star but she's got the
chops to be for it fracking you warts
right it's like so super music like
doesn't need a lead female vocalist like
but it is singing
singing and acting Zakir only known
sports is where there's a Divya the only
reason I give male female what I their
only one I would give meal for them
it allows for more Awards besides you
can't cheer again watching was amazing
but there are some men that were amazing
so that there is something cool about
the idea who is the best actor like this
was it like who won bar a bar none male
female best right who's the best that's
pretty cool
he's butt off and there's one of Oscars
is that right now the Oscars is a Best
Best Male is it always male female yeah
there's always yeah a Supporting male
Best Supporting female and and it's
because it allows for more first of all
the roles are generally different it
allows for more Awards we also want to
see it and I feel like it'd be really
tough you just had one award because boy
you'd have to exclude it we very dope
though think if there's just if one
you'll yeah so they do one actor one
movie there's two [ __ ] Awards at the
Oscars yeah think about the pressure if
you won that [ __ ] yeah yeah best actors
this year out of everybody is yeah and
you just walk around like King
ding-a-ling
yeah cuz you're the best because there's
no doubt that men and women there's no
difference in that it's not like sports
there's no you know you women probably
Meryl sweet spot a greatest actor period
and my for my money than Daniel
day-lewis but you know so I don't know
so they just added this alright I don't
gotta cool they just added it yeah they
still had the men's women's but then
this is just extra one that yeah I
thought that's that like when they
showed the trailer for it like a new
trailer it looks so [ __ ] legit a show
its face those mangy 13 that dress me
know that was a scared me it looks legit
yeah Matt Adam Levine lasted named Adam
in Irvine Levine was the host he's funny
man oh I was heinous - I used to like
him Oh Adam oh yeah that guy I thought
you're talking about this singer no no
Adam is it Levine Levine
I'm Adam Levine - singer room 5 than
Adam yeah I just know that I was making
fun of this singer and I was like I that
guy's such a pretty boy yeah kinda long
I bet he's brilliant I'll see from that
[ __ ] more college is one of my
favorite shows of all time
yeah the other was your own Adam Devine
Adam Levine that Levine
his moon 5 he can sang I'm like I'm
making fun of my guys tattoo making tell
yeah I heard a song and I go this guy's
got a great voice home with this you're
like well that's Adam of I was like ah
deacon bad [ __ ] can is the real
deal I was a notable he very good cuz I
was jealous I was I got tattoos Nadal
thinks he's all cool down Maliki and see
oh and also he's made a Victoria Secret
mom as well he should be
yeah as well he should you can see him
he's got a talent to back it up is a
dime dime tisha
yeah he's special well that's cool
girlfriend you guys have a problem with
it
all those cool yeah gender-neutral right
the next one is Tyson Fury well he's a
according to his promoter says that he's
targeting a July oh hey 400 pounds right
now
it's barely moving I think it'd be a bad
idea for him to come back this soon I
think it's good to keep him focused to
get him on track to fight empty Joshua
I'm not crazy about that fight for
Joshua out of all the guys fury visa to
his toughest matchup he's super awkward
he's [ __ ] be bigger he's a nightmare
to deal with and if you don't follow a
Tyson Fury on Instagram and his boy I
got Billy Baca phrase name Billy Joe I
forget but they're both gypsies or as
gypsies call themselves travelers um
they're both world-class to the best
boxers in the world Billy Joe Simmons I
think his name is but uh they're crazy
yeah absolutely crazy right the crazy
man like you're like eight Billy what do
we do before we practice he's just
singing um Adele they both just start
singing her down
they're like to the [ __ ] big giant
Penn & Teller go to his Instagram Billy
Joel song drums how tall would mr. fury
be catching helix a two six nine six
there you go what a house I think it's
that Titan for you and Billy just on
some fun
he can sing too really yeah he can sing
that's a guy Rita the best already loves
these guys Billy Joe Saunders the world
champion well the best boxer in the
world crazy I already love him go to his
Instagram with her singing though
they're both pretty crazy I love it in
bentleys and [ __ ] and then you know
their gypsy so he goes just buy a new
crib and it's he's like hashtag rich and
with the trailer he's like the
straight-up trailer um scroll down
oh [ __ ] man a beast there's Billy Joe
sunders she's just a kid he is he gives
that you say he gets Joshua he'll go up
go up go to that video right here that
one got it yeah he's uh empty Joshua's
toughest matchup team ritual before
training
[Music]
you can say yes did you see when he beat
Klesko I love him have you seen when he
college oh he gets down on the honor you
seen this girl
no everyone's around oh my God he's
already doing what bring the goat eyes
very extended and then he [ __ ] out
here a lot of song yeah twelve twenty
million people ever done baby goes I
don't want to close my daddy for this
don't want to cause my eyes
get ready flow on here we go oh my god
there is no sand it back cause that boy
years it goes live on HBO by the way the
[ __ ] is this war years ago no no no okay
that goes a colonel one let's go yeah
down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what girl [ __ ] and he was girl crying
he's singing this girl from Lille
looking sold-out arena that's a girl
no she's in the ring fine crowd singing
[Music]
for Hurley this video I'm dodging she
fries
aha I'm so cute we go to Russian
brothers like and AVG please tell the
guys I got just kill him at delivered
and he's on the phone food please try to
enjoy telescope stew oh that's great
you hope funny is that is great good
never sang to me after you [ __ ] won
it's true I shut up what song would you
sing I can't sing like if I was standing
there Brian and you so much older than
me but I love you babe I mean I don't
know he doesn't mean homeboy like so
singers don't wanna go laughing [ __ ]
great not funny
yeah I love that guy hope he gets his
mind right again man for Joshua that's
his big you he's such a colorful
[ __ ] he's Boston ranked him such
a head 100 percentage so fun huh he's
her look at that I did she he's batshit
crazy did so with her date he's great
and he's so you know he has a mansion he
bought a big-ass crib but he lives in
the garage in the caravan that's how he
grew up yeah since when we lived in the
house but he lived in the caravan parked
in the driveway he looks like he feels
like such a sweet person but just be a
good dude yeah good dude had some mental
illness they think so is he younger
Deuter he's older I think he's younger
yeah he's like I thought he was older
they do go to look him up he's not
you know the fight for a long hard
living the stylist [ __ ] also like
awkward God that's where the aim 328 Wow
at least 28 yeah every bit of [ __ ] I
thought it was like in late 30s late I
thought Ford early forties classic the
boxer needs oh who gives a [ __ ]
hope he bike in July for warm-up flights
and vice Joshua but yeah for Joshua
maybe want to keep on you know he's six
foot nine ladies and with an 85 inch
it's 400 pounds I know stand there boy
what else you got - alrighty excellent
on this Nicki Minaj
she is starting to pay people's college
tuitions and then books and all that
stuff just from my from Twitter someone
randomly hit up her up on Twitter its it
could you pay for my schooling she's
like sure
and then for 45 minutes she was paying
for everyone's I know I saw a sure send
me your gray raid your teachers but what
is application we'll just have every
grade the verification it's really you
I'll pay for your college that and then
TMZ hit up those some of those Twitter
people to see if she really did it and
they said yeah why don't pay for it I
love her that's really cool Thomas Cruz
McDuck's right also beautiful if you yes
she's died me die me she's I think she's
half Sri Lankan right
yeah I've no idea yeah yeah black in Sri
Lankan I love America dudes you know
it's a brown long no it's an eclectic
city as in you see everybody from every
corner of the globe is Vancouver no I
mean and they're all and there's just
everybody's included you gotta have my
mum money they got money they got you
know everything I wonder if she was like
oh where you going college like I'm not
showing the Harvick said god damn yeah
yeah it's not gonna be cheap I saw one
of the pictures of the tuition it was
like two thousand something so not like
for the whole tuition I think maybe it
was like the semester something like oh
we saw an edge up adds up though who
knows ahum if she actually paid won the
bid helped further or not like some time
to turn on the radio you know just
whatever radio station was to laughing
like do it out Ryan Seacrest we're to
take care of your bills for the year
hey let me say I'm Ryan Seacrest bills
for a year
let's hit our caller and then she like
hi I'm getting me out of Anaheim and I
need my mission colonies like you know
what I'll do for you we'll take your
like so bill falls on yeah and I'm like
well that's like seven hundred dollars
you know like it helps to be good but
you know I can take care of my mortgage
bibs
hey Ryan Seacrest your riches lot going
to take your that Morgan in two thousand
and I think two thousand cuz I uh I was
doing a TV show and I was making thirty
five grand an episode oh you told us
this yesterday about this yeah and I'm
and I'm ballin and a friend of mine
needed some cash and to open this thing
and I was like let me write you a
$35,000 other your charity well okay yes
I gave that but I did the other one was
I gave this guy
thirty-five grand I was like go ahead
and knock yourself out because
thirty-five is the number right I was
like I'm making thirty five an episode
new help me up stood to shoot well I
ended up shooting 13 and it got
cancelled so you're not the best with
money hell nah buddy
no I'm not at all good any luck that
idea though yeah uh yes socially yeah I
always get a motive in stay with those
things like they were so about pizza for
her life
yeah I figure yet to win for pizza for
life that I [ __ ] with why I guess I
get in guilty right so I feel guilty if
and there's another really good out of a
paternity action smile with a fixed
cleft palates around yeah and that's
that's a you know so I always try to
find the ones I can give to but I feel
guilty when I
I just if I'm making like a lot of money
like that I just felt like oh man I I
don't know you I mean I I know and feel
deal table that's all time to get CL
upin that's also being stupid because
you have kids and a wife you got a kid
yeah now I do is you can take care like
this is helping out and being generous
than this being stupid
yeah there's being stupid yes I'd be
stupid and I know a lot of actors some
very famous who have given out millions
of dollars let so that football player
ends one day his name football player
signed this huge signing bonus young guy
white receiver invested
all his money in flying cars seriously
it was crunk about it - did he need
someone to talk to him don't you talk to
anybody unmanned Hillbillies dude I had
guys come to me about a water machine
I'd say this no they these three guys
came to me about how they have a machine
that takes water out of the atmosphere
at the air which there is a machine like
that was and and they said you know that
if I invest now I'll be the first tier
investor and my my my money will double
and then triple it when we get the next
round of investors that Ponzi [ __ ] so
I'm listening these [ __ ] guys getting
more and more angry because they had to
put my friend into it didn't know how
long does this um simply ten years all
kids he didn't know me that's the and I
go um but I got family that her money
people I go hey let me ask you guys
something then how much of your own
money do you have invested in this yeah
when the guy goes can I answer that the
other guy starts stammers it's not our
job to invest that money our job - rich
okay good so then when you guys put your
money and you let me know how that goes
and I'll come in for the second tier
how's that sound
yeah let's always ask that if somebody
comes to you for money you and they want
you investment company run the other way
run the other way but if they corner you
say how much of your own money do you
have that's very the other thing where
people get screwed you know we write an
iShare a money person who deals with you
know all the billing and Psyche and all
that stuff but when you give them to me
I don't give a [ __ ] if it was your mom's
best friend growing up you know for 40
years you're right if you give someone
all the access to everything you just
assume they're dot in the eyes and
crossing the t's you're doing yourself a
disservice man like I have like and you
know this B I have every check we have
come to me first
I'm mark Takai describe them take
pictures I send to Brian and then I send
tour grams people because that's how
people get [ __ ] over because you have
income come from all these different
places and then they go either taking
care of it maybe yeah maybe they miss
something or maybe they'd spend money on
this they're doing this or they're doing
this so I know I know what so look at
the last
Morissette she had five million dollars
stolen from her sting had a fortune
stolen from him
um Robert De Niro Al Pacino had a no way
yeah for sure this guy Ken Starr went to
jail he was the same way he basically
was stealing money from all his actor
Col that that guy who did all the
football players was seeing died to left
over all the football player didn't
cooks brother yeah yep it's the list
goes on and on and on I know the guy who
was it who owned [ __ ] anyway um his son
was a good friend of mine and was in my
acting class and a great guy so I won't
mention the name but he owned a big film
company and they had five hundred
million dollars because he had started
EarthLink and they had their money was
invested with this guy and this guy who
was their money manager kept pretending
to pay taxes then they get a bill for
like three hundred million dollar one
hundred million dollars for taxes maybe
we have it and they had to sell
everything and now agreed then we're
living and I'm you know it's bad bad be
careful talk to people and no dude I was
watching that show founder last night
Bell founder it's a it's a loosely based
you know it's a movie but documentary
style I want it it's a movie but it's
based off how McDonald's got as big as
they did you know story there's like two
brothers I heard they're in San
Bernardino California my okay that was
just a yeah there's just like a you know
a little place is I think is called
McDonald's and they had all this stuff
on their menus like all this all sorts
of [ __ ] and they want to be more
efficient and did not use such a high
payroll so I don't want as many
employees so I [ __ ] man what's the
only thing that sells hamburgers and
fries and shakes that's what the [ __ ]
we're going to do so you got rid of
everything else just did that did no
service nothing you have to go to the
window to order at the time back then
you have Drive thrus right like where
people park and the waitress come out
maybe unroll ur blade something like
that they like cigarette stuff like that
so these guys figure out to make it so
efficient and not have a restaurant this
is the first fast-food chain that the
they only offered [ __ ] cheeseburgers
fries and that's it and is there
on-demand they could roll them out fast
off so Michael Keaton's care
to the movie the guy whose [ __ ] ball
and Richard died in 1987 he see he was
going around selling these milkshake
machines and he comes in over two months
reviews it walks up he's like holy [ __ ]
man look at this look how efficient is
and he goes you guys franchised this he
was I have this vision gives me a
franchise they they're hesitant towards
that I go we tried it sucked in Long
Beach Trenton friend is ignited I know
what we're gonna do so he takes their
business model and blows it up to what
the [ __ ] it is different Connells but
you know those two guys who started were
super nice so they're like we don't want
ruffle any feathers and and my team has
the quote and that's an actual quote
from the guy he goes let me ask you if
your competition comes your doorstep are
you willing to do [ __ ] anything to
make it work
are you willing to [ __ ] you know if
you saw your competition drowning what
would you do and they're like well
probably help amuse you know what I do I
put a [ __ ] hose in his mouth and make
sure he stays under he's are you willing
to do that may you know so eventually he
has him signed a contract he really just
takes the business from yeah they get
paid I think they made like 1.3 million
each
yeah but he's obviously he made
something I don't know he what bill I
know that story and I was thinking about
it and like in my opinion like that kind
of guy that if that guy didn't come
along there would be no McDonald's right
and so here is your like that he's kind
of [ __ ] up but then I go is he [ __ ]
up because he took what you guys are
doing it may be excess or letter way one
you know McDonald's feeds 1% of a
population every day yeah 1% I didn't
know that but that's a man 1% will
publish it man McDonald's a lot of
McDonald's our community centers for
under so we're a lot of poor people I'll
be fast food the way to go but yeah they
say Padma it's also food it's it's clean
and it's also a place where a lot of
communities don't have parks or too cold
without any work and that's where a lot
of communities that are underprivileged
a lot of the elder yeah elderly come and
gather and meet they can have a meal so
there's a lot about McDonald that boy
that McDonald's dude he changed the
everyone copied him and I was thinking
about my planner but you watch it and I
he's kind of an ass by watching oh he's
an ass but he's a businessman he saw a
better way and those guys were in the
way the only bad I met he did
the fucked-up thing he did he the one
they sold them he got all the rights all
the business everything towards him he
gave him 1.3 1.3 million thinking I was
back in the fifth month alot of money
back down my and that's what his lawyer
said more mine in a man he goes this is
a shitload of money as you're looking at
running it this right now is once you
own it two complete different ones was
like a billion dollars but he goes up so
he pays in that money and I was want to
stop here because you were saying about
the one facing dog days ago so yet he
goes well we want 1% of royalties every
year for the rest of my life
he was deal deal you got that which
today would be 166 million dollars every
year since I never get it like 180 since
1980 there we got 166 members each per
year it's a lot of money then we got 1.3
a lot of money but he was in the meeting
of as investors if I promise you guys
he's one puts percent royalties I can't
grow the business so you have my word I
will give you the royalties I promise
you I'll give my shake on it when I can
put in contract let's shake on it
they shake out and you tell the guys
face and obvious the movies was dramatic
but he knows yeah I need never gave him
those royalties yeah that's the bad
thing ship how many billions it won't
[ __ ] come on that's that's a kind of guy
though I mean I would say this that guy
in his mind you know probably said these
guys got you know I gave them two point
six million dollars collectively and
they are they'll never be they'll never
be able to take this business any
further than they have it right now
they're in the way and I'm going to
literally sue because if you think about
it I feel it feels he took a he took he
made a new business change one day it
change the game in if you took your idea
and Larry and they were in the way and
in a way I bet you in his mind he's like
I don't think they deserve one percent I
also don't know if he's if he's a bad
guy because I I'll deal with
negotiations where I do it myself
instead of using my manager a lot of
times and my magical dude he took
advantage of you he like it's terrible
man they did did usually he should be
doing this and paying for this this is
my manager goes it's not if he said
something's not day's a bad guy but he's
gonna take what units right in there
there's a dollar every one of them he's
gonna take him
his business sure he's not a shark not
that person it's bad now I've always
left it in with ours when you walk I
think you think the car salesman the
evil dude nah man he's gonna get every
dime you can incorrect is not a bad guy
but if you don't do your research you
know what the [ __ ] you're doing didn't
take advantage that's right I've had to
happen was young it [ __ ] sucks let's
get you all right the next one this is a
really feel good one so this little girl
she's from England and I guess she grew
up or she was really really young she
had to get her leg amputated poor thing
someone sent me this from Instagram
which is really cool and then so this is
her friends seeing her with a new
prosthetic leg and this is just children
being children does the initial reaction
how they reacted so I'll play the little
clip of it so this is her coming to her
schoolyard this is England in England
and these are friends checking our leg
out for the first time it's cool they
cool I got to tell her that's gonna be
normal
oh so they just give her hugs poor
little bunny and they're just really
happy for oh very cool you know it's
cool and then they just do their own
thing and play we get a move how cool is
she technology head I can thank God a
little critters God Anna that's amazing
that's cool man everything is a new
blade for you blade it's great - really
guy let's get darker really got
Petrosian no yeah petroi troyius
Petrosian Oscar Petraeus not before
patrols unit you talked about the runner
the Sprinter yeah - victorious person
larger pistol racin remember that guy
yeah he's one fast like me bros complain
like uh those things actually helping
him yeah and then he murdered his die
piece girl she got like eight years old
edu no way I know how swollen I mean no
no God - Sheree still in jail yeah he's
in jail he's out
he got house Rustin got out yeah pretty
sure I thought he got retried didn't get
off and then you got retried he's
convicted of murder since of six years
in prison for girlfriend's murder six
years people jeez that's not
that at all did you see how gorgeous she
was yeah oh [ __ ] you got one leg yeah
and you pull that die piece and you kill
her
yeah I mean manslaughter since Tim to
five years in prison
look he's certain though check this one
time I get out of there
how long SEC he served a year of that
sentence released on house arrest in
October Wow
but oh court appeals overturn the
verdict Westheimer found him guilty of
murder
pills chair tip story should have known
that firing his gun would have killed
whoever was behind the door garage who
it was the minimum prison sentence for
murder and satellite was fifteen years
and the prosecution had called for no
less for the defense try to secure
Schwarzenberg and his disability and
emotional state were mitigating factors
okay I'm giving him six years mm-hmm
so he went for six so he's in childen
right yeah for six years
[ __ ] but that's nothing do you hear what
happened he's girl you know whatever you
got their argument and all that [ __ ] and
they're saying he had a gun and she's
behind the door he fired the gun but
they like come on yeah i Mena not he
push and I think that leg
I was at one of the first peoples like
that leg totally helps them win those
races yeah yeah I'm sure totally felt
that it's like the rat don't even run it
sucks with their doom but when it comes
to sports oh it's just booze weed black
and white here like you seen those
wrestlers like see homeboy I forget his
name but phenomenal wrestler world-class
but because he's missing is his leg yeah
or his legs
yeah you know you have a 200-pound man
upper body wrestling at once it defeats
150 and just getting a hold his
[ __ ] he gets ahold of him that's
locked yeah but you know he's winning
you know it's hard I get a double leg
yeah all right what else you got
and I thought the shooting was BS -
there's no he for sure did a bad dude
God talk about [ __ ] up your life man
talk about just ruining your life and
that girl was a South African milk show
princess all right back on the happy
train Conor McGregor had his baby mamas
that's awesome and then in Whitey's pote
like one of these posts or pictures he
put the doll we don't have
and Mia's facial expression is crazy
we can land the left Paul from anywhere
who wants it altitude is that great my
word the great Conor McGregor his name's
Conor McGregor juniors all right yeah
Conor Jackson burger something like that
Jonathan McGregor cute good for him
that's amazing she looks so green and
yeah love it
little CGI brother nothing too crazy the
zebra that escaped
oh hell yeah I can't walk his erupts
okay zebra charges Florida home on
remember they bite you and hold on
no not like yes are they like horses not
like horses okay bigger cannot
domesticate a zebra that you cannot
that's what I'm saying where's eborhood
that's right and they will fight and
hold on you're on hold on are they as
big as a horse no smaller than oars
they're small that's give or see I'm
running that's him running that's him
running I was just trotting along where
the [ __ ] is he in the middle of the
colored Florida that looks like if where
Florida's does that much desert or that
let's probably beach then they have like
lakes and stuff either I have beach sand
around it I made but yeah some guy was
walking his dogs outside and just
suddenly ran into a zebra and the zebra
just charged him but didn't hurt him and
then he ended up hitting a truck and
then they they corralled them with like
the the guys that knew knew the zebra
the owners and like sheriff officials
you see that [ __ ] anaconda they found
no I don't know if it's true but it's
they think it's 33 feet and their weight
it weighed 400 kilograms American pounds
no they were detonating this cave and I
think in Brazil hey bro and they found a
giant anaconda in anaconda Brazil cave
yeah 33
did you read it or so told you no I saw
it I read all really yeah crazy now you
got it there you go anaconda
terrifying 33 PAH
well I get to get a tracker to get
sucked into Yelp that's like the thing
that [ __ ] up jail on the side of it
look at its head oh my word eat you look
at how big it is dude the mainland they
kept them alive right let's see this
this is crazy
it's not playing keeps going LLL say
let's see it's claimed that the builders
top killed the snake rather than leaving
its own that to have that but this is a
big killed it why would you kill that
[ __ ] magical animal I'd rather look
at it why would you kill it what would
you call that
it seems [ __ ] sterically I'm also if
you're you were bearing into a cave
where you live yeah and then you kill
him that day like that thing was a giant
that thing it L monster oh my god
see how much slurry Sonny anacondas are
so far for me with 800 pounds of
something crazy I mean not that of us
either they'll eat you alive now that
thing I'll eat you that thing if you're
walking by scale they've caught you me
he's dead for sure people saw me what
else you got chin
I think that's it I got get up noetic DK
for us the gas in a condo there's a good
one I'm reading about like just how what
the economy is doing and how you know
it's reading about this lepen phenomenon
we're both on Obamacare Obamacare is a
good example of this so we have off
feels good
ah Obamacare I like when your hands on
me like that thank you I don't want
cancer oh good hey I'm sensitive little
I don't like cancers [ __ ] god it's
like what mad judges in the NBA when
they was HIV positive people were
terrifying up dose one oh my god though
they were garden like this you know bro
go go solo
good old it sure up to shoot just know
and now he's a billionaire it's a good
kind of Oh pay for that sweat in his
Starbucks coffee data some the Pew
Research Center so that we crossed the
historical threshold last year for the
first time and more than a hundred and
thirty years
adults ages 18 to 34 were more likely to
be living in their parents home
that's cream they were to be living with
a spouse or partner in their own
household why
fully one quarter of Americans between
25 and 29 live with a parent compared
with only 18 percent just a decade ago
it's the economy it's that you know
there are a lot of factors it might also
be that as you get a little bit not as
much pressure to have children and a
wife is you don't have to grow up as
quickly but also you know there are
whole communities that are imploding
all the things like globalism and stuff
like that you know what were industries
in communities and deep communities you
know communities that go back
generations that those industries have
died let me ask you they know P do you
think the reason why people in you know
just people into the 30s living with
their parents stuff like that it's a
cultural thing in America we don't play
that [ __ ] but Mexican cultures Italian
cultures Afghanistan code English
cultures they do it with your but in
America we don't play that [ __ ] when
you're 16 really 18 get the [ __ ] out it
yeah but they're saying now to your
point it is more of a trend of people
staying later later
I think it's parents enabling the kids a
lot of times I like because this day and
age a lot of kids they want it now has
happened fast and that embraced the
grind to use DC's kind of terminology
that grind that you don't see if you
Basie actually though in innovation in
American culture actually that still
stands I get out there and find your own
way but it already belong to economists
but even in America the the statistics
are increasing that people over the age
of 30 are still living the past well
let's see part of this is also though
and one of the reasons that a lot of
political pundits and economists talk
about why Trump won was because you have
huge swathes of this country where
parents are seeing their kids go out
there after getting into debt with
college or whatever and they can't find
jobs they just can't and and they can't
certainly can't find meaningful jobs or
if they do they have to go away and so
those deep communities that had these
industries that would support generation
after generation and forge really strong
ties and communities have disintegrated
have imploded the same thing is
happening in Europe and so that's part
of the reason that Trump had such an
appeal to a lot of people you know
people always say well Trump supporters
are race no they're not no they're not
it's not they just want some change or
is it matter who I yeah man Trump
supporters were like we're not sharing
the American Dream and this is
something's going on so a lot of it is a
lot of economists that'll study the
stuff say that really the trend is
mostly because of that because there is
major economic upheaval there are
industries that are coming and leaving
having said that though apparently we're
almost at full employment
yeah so still somewhat something's going
right I think it's interesting though
that in other cultures I
my girls told Mexican family like her
brother still lives in the house and you
know my girls still like it's just like
no way like the parents like no I'll
stay here tiny like family cooking and
everything like that but like straight
white people but as you get [ __ ] out
at 18 I did my job you can sit out very
much
Koreans exactly like I feel like you're
you're saying same as white people no
your girl's family really doesn't matter
how old me and my brother get they want
us to get married and come back and live
live with them and have one big happy
soul that's all they want I don't mind
that I like that idea
English English family two men like my
my uncle grandma and aunt they all live
together they will never get it like a
block away like it's very nervous that
way Europe you don't know your gram your
parents do not go to a home your parents
come into your house when they're really
oh yeah
and you keep everybody together yeah I'm
a fan of now I'm not I'm white as [ __ ]
yeah Tiger you got yeah yeah fifty more
years Wow
get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] get out like a
party to attend their unwanted boarding
school at six and seven
I can't that's great that's good for him
well Oh buddy come see I'll go to the
diamond you know what no come see Bryan
in Denver before he dies right before I
pass away ladies gentlemen if you need
me I will not be in the Sun I'll be
wearing a hat and sunglasses go
beekeeper still funny though
oh yeah the personality still there
feels like a Big Papi the funny
beekeeper ladies and gentlemen I'll be
live on PA
Yuri why this [ __ ] these days I can't
talk to you in this on just talk to me
in the in the shade maybe you at the
Denver Comedy Works in dare is a Friday
Saturday downtown Denver I can't wait
one of my favorite gigs one of my
favorite clubs I know we a do fun kid
yeah we do yeah we do I get down the
regards I'm getting back to Denver
forever and then Oh fie the kid is live
in Oklahoma
Cherokee Casino keep saying Colusa it's
actually Cherokee Casino one night only
that [ __ ] is almost sold out take it
that tea fat K calm then I am headed to
Australia tickets on sale May 11th I'm
at Brisbane Oakland Sydney Melbourne why
that [ __ ] is nothing Melbourne Melbourne
Melbourne Melbourne and that is January
or June 6th through the 10th those
tickets available May 11th everything
t5k comms tief @k tom I'll have a
limited-edition Australian tea for that
ass as well which one I'm the Comedy
Store with Rogan Diaz
[ __ ] it a bunch of killers awesome
that's the world man
ladies and gentlemen hey another great
Monday don't die on us beer I go to the
doctor now let me suck that cancer out
for you
alright this is a finally kid we're out